عروض مذهله وحافله مفتوحه احتفاليه
مانشستر سيتي بالثلاثيه
بعد بنزيما اتحاد جده يستهدف ضم نجم
مانشستر سيتي الانجليزي
وابواب الهلال السعودي مغلقه امام هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم عبر العربيه
رياضه اسعدوا في متابعتكم
[موسيقى]
كشف نادي مانشستر سيتي الانجليزيه عن
تفاصيل الاحتفالات التي سيقوم بها غدا
الاثنين بمناسبه تتويج بثلاثيه للمره
الاولى في تاريخه اداره النادي اعلنت عبر
موقعها الرسميه عن اقامه احتفال في ساحه
مركز مدينه مانشستر
وسيتضمن حضور عدد
من لعب اقامه حفل موسيقي ومن المقرر ان
يطوف لاعب مانشستر سيتي بحافله مفتوحه في
مشهد مشابه لما قام به نجوم مانشستر
يونايتد الانجليزي عند التتويج
بالثلاثه عام 199
ونبقى مع نهاائي دوري ابطال اوروبا الذي
شهد تضامنا مع الدولي البرازيلي فينيسيوس
جونيور لاعب ريال مدريد الاسباني وتحديدا
حول ازمته مع العنصريه ففي الحبل الذي سبق
المباراه النهائيه ظهرت المغنيه
البرازيليه انيكا على المسرح وهي ترتدي
قميصا يحمل اسم فينيسيوس جونيار على ظهره
ما رد فينيسوس على رساله التضامن هذه بنشر
صور للمغنيه من الحفل على جميع منصاته على
السوشيال ميديا وكتب معها
تفاعل رواد السوشيال ميديا اليوم مع خبر
نشرته صحيفه سبورت الاسبانيه حول تقديم
اتحاد جده السعودي لعرض للاعب مانشستر
سيتي الانجليزي جوند الصحيفه اكدت ان
اللاعب يحظى ايضا باهتمام من قبل اداره
برشلونه الراغبه بالتوقيع معه عبر صفقه
مجانيه لكنها اوضحت انه اذا كانت قرارات
اللاعب تعتمد على المقابل المادي فانه بلا
شك سيقرر مزاملتك كريم بنزيما
اتحاد جده
تفاعل رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي حول
الانتقالات امتد ايضا لتغريده الايطالي
فبريزيو رومانو خبير الانتقالات الشهير
والتي كشف فيها عن رغبه اداره التعاون
السعودي بضم المهاجم الارجنتيني المعارض
من باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي الى جالاتا
اسرائيل التركي حتى نهايه الموسم الحالي
الصحفي الايطالي اكد ان المفاوضات ما زالت
في مراحل مبكره وان ايكارت سيدرس العرض
وهو سعيد جدا مع فريقه التركي لكنه لم
يتخذ اي قرار حتى الان منتظرا ما سيقرر
باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي
اطلقت جماهير الهلال السعودي واسما اعلنت
فيه رفضها التعاقد مع اليغري مدرب يوفنتوس
الايطالي بعد ساعات قليله فقط
صحفيه كشفت فيه عن رغبه النادي في التعاقد
معه وسم جمهور الهلال يرفض اليغري تصدر
موقع تويتر واحتل المركز الثالث بين
الكلمات الاكثر تداولا في السعوديه